I'm talking to Justin in Jacksonville
Florida struggling with gambling
blackjack and used to play poker years
ago and doing some stuff online now and
making a couple hundred a year got no
money broke it's all going to that and
took a couple Lexus payments and some
credit cards is that a fair summary of
what you told me pretty much yep okay
and how old are you 29 29 cool okay
well I'll be 34 come on here's what I
know and you've got to make some
decisions okay we work with people with
financial trouble and have for 30 years
and we do a lot of one-on-one coaching
as a part of that what we have found is
a guy named Larry Burkett used to teach
this stuff decades ago and he used to
say financial problems including when I
went broke Justin the financial problems
are almost never the problem they're
really the symptom of something else
going on sometimes it's something as
simple as immaturity sometimes it's
greed in my case it was way too much
ambition and so I grew too fast I bought
a whole bunch of real estate nothing
down I had four million dollars for the
real estate 3 me and our three million
dollars worth of debt and the bank
called her notes and we went broke when
I was your age and I hit bottom so I did
stupid with zeros on the end in other
words and so that started this whole
thing of us teaching people how to
handle money gods and grandmas ways now
having done coaching for 30 years around
here here's what we've discovered the
fastest-growing addiction in North
America today is online pornography and
it is destroying thousands and thousands
of households a day because guys get in
that and it just it starts it starts
eating money the second fastest growing
addiction is online gambling faster than
cocaine
yeah well pornography is a larger has a
larger revenue base than all
professional sports put together now
larger than Hall it's it's an
unbelievable
evil industry and but the anyway so the
point is is that you're dealing with a
monster that a lot of other people are
dealing with and online accessibility
versus having to get in your car and
drive to the casino is making it worse
would you agree 100% and on top of that
I work from home so it's like there you
have the you have the disadvantage of
isolation yeah that you can sneak off in
secret so to speak even though it's not
really that secret but I mean it's you
don't have anybody looking over your
shoulder going what are you doing you
know yeah you know and that kind of
thing and that's really really dangerous
so what I'm telling you from an
intellectual standpoint you're dealing
with an emotional issue with an
addiction but from an intellectual
standpoint it'll help you fight it is
you're dealing with a very large and
powerful monster and it is not to be
toyed with 100 percent of the people who
have addictive behaviors that we work
with either correct the addictive
behaviors by getting some help or they
go broke there is no in-between it will
eat your life and you will depending on
how extreme it gets you lose family
you'll lose everything I mean so I'm
trying to scare you
because you got to do something with
this dude for your sake so here's what
we would tell Pete you if you came into
our office we don't treat addictions
here but we obviously with a lot of
people who are facing addictive
behaviors or full-on addictions and I
don't know where you are in that
spectrum doesn't matter right now you're
just - these are just two guys talking
I'm not a therapist anyway but I woke up
in your shoes and was scared about that
what I would do would be I would hit it
from its kind of getting cancer I would
hit it from about three or four
different fronts I want to have them I
want to have the tumor removed and I
want to have every possible treatment
and and I want everybody praying for me
I want to hit it from every possible
angle right and so the first thing I do
is find a Gamblers Anonymous group it is
that has the highest success rate of
anything in addiction to get people out
are the 12 steps and plug into it I know
you
don't probably feel like you're at that
point and I don't know if you are not
but go over there and there and years
ago yeah I go back any time okay go back
and you know what you're in for then
you're inferring people who love you and
people who will speak truth brutally
because they love you
and the second thing I would do is or
have you guys ever been involved in a
church no okay now we're not very
religious honestly yeah I don't
understand understand well what happens
is is there's with addictions there's
several different elements obviously
emotions emotional and mental is part of
it but spiritual is part of it as well
and I you know when I was your age I was
somewhat like you about this same
subject so I would recommend you visit
and talk with a local pastor and begin
to a turn attend some worship services
even if you you know don't totally buy
in that's cool I'm okay with that but
just let's attack this cancer from every
possible angle let's get GA involved
let's get spiritual walk involved I also
would look up and find a one-on-one
therapist a one-on-one a counselor that
deals with this and meet one-on-one I
mean you got to be really really sure
that you that you're coming completely
clean with your wife on all of this and
that she knows exactly where you are
because it's your only shot at keeping
her around she's going to get really
tired of the lying very fast
am I wrong you know luckily I do have a
great relationship with her we just got
married three months ago and you know
she's aware she's aware I don't I don't
I don't make lies good no yeah you
haven't been sucked in too far yet then
because a really bad at the one thing I
didn't know about them as they lie all
the time I was there there years ago I
lied I stole no I I did whatever I had
to do you know at that time at this
point where I am now you know the
money's just coming
you know like close the deal I get a
large sum and if I lose it I tell myself
oh well I got another deal closer next
weeks now you know I'll be able to pay
the bills with that and then next thing
you know I go in the hole and then
that's that next check is paying off
debt you know what I mean yeah you know
that's a circle dog training style you
know exactly and I'm live I find myself
living deal the deal I'm I you know I've
done I've closed deals where I've made
seventy thousand I'm living you know but
do you know yeah and I think I hear you
saying you're afraid you're going to go
all the way back down that rabbit hole
to where you used to be and you're not
there yet not there yet I don't want to
be there but you know how to get there
sure and you're on the road you're on
that road that's the road you're driving
on Harry you know that's why you called
me I'm just a guy man I'm not I'm not a
counselor I don't know what I'm doing
it's just two guys here talking but
that's what you're telling me I know no
that's what I heard
that's so yeah if I were you I would put
some people in my life like ga a
one-on-one coach a church my wife and
you know if you've got to throw the
computer in the back yard or you got to
buy some kind of filter system that
doesn't allow you to go want some of
these blocking systems or whatever I
don't even know how you do it anymore
there used to be a whole filter
attendant idea that you can keep people
from going to a gambling site keeps you
from going to a porn site keeps you from
going to anything is you don't transfer
one addiction for another either that
happens a lot and so but you know what
you're telling me is is you know the
danger signs because you've been there
before and you're seeing them and you're
saying what do I do
so I'm telling you get like six
different points of contact around this
to kill it let's kill this beast forever
and ever and in GA one-on-one coaching
one-on-one counseling a good church
friends family wife everybody gets some
practical tactical measures where you
just don't do that you may want to quit
working from home you may want to find a
way to work out of an office somewhere
looked into that we had an office for a
while didn't work out I have a business
partner you know that we we live you
know about an hour away from each other
so it's hard to find
I don't care yeah yeah you're right this
is this is it to it there's a $200,000
your problem do if it takes that for you
to get well so you can get on with your
life because if you get this monkey off
your back you're a guy who produces
you're making a serious box and you're
broke you you don't need to be broke
making this kind of money so we got to
get monkey you got to get this monkey
off your back so you have a life yeah so
that's what I would do call me back and
tell me how it turns out only here the
rest a story I'll hear what you really
get are you hope you're gonna do this if
you don't do it man there is no middle
ground for people facing what you're
facing it's all in one way though
they're all in for the healing are all
in for the hell which one you gonna sign
up for